citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tara Erickson alongside this guy it was
just his birthday
Eva turned 45. everybody get in the chat
be like Happy 45th birthday old jokes
are only about you I know but like I
switched it it's like a switch in
Reverse for today no I cannot take it he
can't he can't a woman can take you are
programmed to be strong and belittled by
men
not I have Mom issues and now you have
triggered all that good luck because his
walls are not as strong as mine and we
are watching How to Train Your Dragon
too so we both might cry
you said that people said that it's like
a better one for a thing and we don't
know I'm not 100 confident I've seen
this one but I think I have I have not I
I've only heard the Train Your Dragon 2
is also very very good trilogies the
whole trilogy is amazing you called it I
forget what you called it coming of
Christ headache
okay guys don't forget you gotta leave a
like yeah you gotta get in there you
gotta comment you also have to ring that
foreign
reactions the whole entire thing is on
patreon so you got to get up get in
there get super sexy because we call you
super sexy rejects when you get on the
patreon so join up you'll see all their
full-long reactions watch alongs all
that as well as this one as well as this
one exclusively over there yeah we do
too we all have a little page here for
Tara to read and uh I just figured I'm
sitting here that you guys know but this
video hopefully the editors will switch
that around don't forget
don't forget that this video with me and
Greg can be seen on patreon okay sync up
with your own copy and watch along the
whole entire movie I think we're ready
to watch the Dragon movie are you yeah I
think the three minute intro is good
enough yeah
[Music]
you see where most folks enjoy Hobbies
like whittling or needlepoint we
burkeyans prefer
oh we like to call
Dragon Racing oh fun that's what they're
doing now cool here you go babe
can I tell you that you look amazing
today because you do come on barf
starting to stink around here nope still
hates you was he into her in the last
one I don't remember the guy who was
just talking I don't remember him but I
remember the other two they're gonna win
now whatever she wants she gets didn't
she try to bury you alive only for a few
hours hey that's that's flirting
we have custom Stables all you can eat
feeding stations a full-service Dragon
wash how fun
the black sheep come on I love animation
sequels it's always so much more refined
yeah I feel like this one looks even
more like sharper sharpness yes the
sharpness of the images like moment
have a nice flight
I'm like these sheep have to be like I
hate this game yeah
oh
yes yes here you go darling mine's worth
I'm totally winning we're winning
together
we're attached genius quit trying to
steal all my glory
Astrid you are so cool no sheep no glory
Ah that's my future daughter-in-law so
they still dating or engaged now oh yeah
engaged
wow this this would get me so nauseous
because with Vikings on the backs of
dragons the world just got a whole lot
bigger
how so ah yeah what's toothless doing
where are we going take us there oh cool
oh my God what's the upgrade here whoa
his
that's him in that costume yeah
damn look at him he's a professional
writer wow he also looks like he's ready
for some BDSM slightly I mean not in a
weird way I'm just saying this is a kids
movie I know but I'm just like what's up
with the thing like the it's a lot maybe
he's ready for medieval times I should
say but sometimes I get the two confused
[Laughter]
so what do you think Bud he's got a
pumpkin oh does he what on his shoulder
pad I love everything about who he has
become since he lost a little bit of his
leg and got a dragon oh he's
free-falling awesome
how cool oh no way that is so cool
suit oh my God he invented squirrel
suits I just got goosebumps you guys and
I'm not joking
[__]
oh my goodness
how inventive amazing how inventive
that's so cool
personal hot air balloon
okay I like that I like that showing you
that they don't have it completely
together yet right that there's still
some obstacles to overcome but I love
how creative they're getting with the
aerodynamic stuff man
hey handsome do they age him of yeah he
looks older absolutely
[Music]
oh pretty ah looks like we found another
one bud oh what do you want an apology
apology
oh my God it's so cute I can't see oh
wow
you know that doesn't wash out
[Music]
that laugh this is so great I didn't
even think about the amount of exploring
you could do now that you have a truck
oh yeah like he oh he's like building a
map that's why he said we found it
that's awesome I think we might find a
few Timberjacks in those woods maybe
we'll finally track down another night
fury oh his family oh my God then you
could have baby night fairies and sell
the night furies
or just keep them all forever nope
monetization
winning races what else
I signed her down to breakfast thinking
all is right with the world and I get
son we need to talk not
now
and since no Chief could ask for a
better successor I've decided thank you
chief
God he doesn't want it all those
speeches and planning and running the
village that's his thing you're a leader
I
you know exactly who you are you always
have but I'm still looking I love this
attention to detail of the animals rough
playing together yeah but I'm not my
father and I never met my mother so what
does that make me why do you need to
have met your mother to know who you are
what you're searching for isn't out
there it's in here maybe you just don't
see it yet
great attention to detail it doesn't
wash off
Oh I thought it's burning
[Music]
Heroes afloat
whoa it really stands out in this
environment are we about to meet the
villain of this story it looks like it
protruded from within the water like
yeah it does it was like a big
oh is it like oh like ice mixed with
like a a rack magic
yeah magic
pick up
oh what are they doing oh no sir what is
going on
they came here to check up on you
if you hurt that Dragon you all die
oh this is so cruel no I hate it
Papa
what is whoa
uh they're Dragon Hunters look we don't
want any trouble he should have thought
of that before you stole all of our
dragons and blasted our Fort to [__]
so they do they tame Dragons Dragon
trapping it's hard enough work as it is
without Duke of Dragon Riders sneaking
in to rescue them there are other Dragon
Riders you mean other than your thieving
friend from last night you tell me
deceiving friend he's expecting a new
shipment of dragons for his army by
tomorrow this is what he gave me last
time I showed up empty-handed that's
that BDSM you were talking about
foreign
[Music]
finest dragon trap were a lie it's not
just anyone who can capture a Night Fury
no
what no oh [__] oh good job toothless
yeah yeah yeah go go
that sucks they came here to check up to
see if people needed help Drogo is
coming for them all right you think
that's his real name Drago yeah just
happens it's absolutely
one letter yeah yes I think it was a
choice
yeah probably flown off the edge of the
world by now do you want that kid
running the village you can still delay
your retirement oh oh cool upgrades they
probably think they're like impenetrable
with the amount of dragons they have
like completely unaware yeah yes like
that yeah yeah well they also never knew
that there were other Dragon Riders out
there this is actually a little more
important than building Saddles ah
lesson two no task is too small when it
comes to sell finger people
his dad still is the problem of not
listening very well yeah
these guys Dragon Trappers
are gonna get yourselves Insidious
trouble one of these days
it's a really funny physical comedies
they are building a dragon Army Dargo
bloody Fester something
it's not hard to remember the name
Dragon oh I think stoic knows who this
guy is fist
wait what is happening
and this one has like a menace to it
was like a like a Darkness yeah yeah it
really like feels like it's coming to
the surface we can't wait around for him
to get here let's go find him and change
his mind yeah change his mind back is
what you need to worry about I
takes his own nope you gotta switch it
up I don't want to see the other dragons
die I really don't I can't even not war
please no oh good job he's gonna just go
maybe he can change his mind the power
of communication yeah man we don't need
to go to war go get it Ingrid
oh I don't think it's Ingrid oh it's not
what's her name you called her Ingrid I
thought it was Astrid oh [__] or maybe
you actually did call her Astrid and
I've been calling her Ingrid
is it Ingrid no I'm confused now I'm
ready I think it's we don't know it's
the blonde girl that's his girlfriend
names are not our specialty they're
really not
going away this time
no no
they were prepared we give up
stay
what the show they'll just hang out with
you they won't be any trouble
unless you do that Wooden Boats big
ocean how is your swimming not good
the guy seemed sad about his bad
swimming can't have armed Prisoners the
other sprays hideous sippleback gas
spark and
oh oh once they see you as one of their
own even the testiest dragons can be
trained oh oh he's being clever
what game are you playing trying to show
that you can Bond
I go oh good job dragon go fast
you won't be changing any Minds around
here I can change yours may I what what
just happened
oh is that Stoke shocks they got him put
me down it's not loud what are you doing
oh yeah yeah got it I think they're
saving him okay
[Music]
oh no oh my God no you do not you oh my
God
of all the irresponsible I'm trying to
protect our dragons and stop a war how
is that irresponsible because war is
what you want son but he's trying
years ago there was
a gathering of Chief
dragon skills
skirt yes I remember came a stranger
from a Strange Land covered in scars and
draped in a cloak of dragon skin picture
dragon skin
was a man of the people he claimed that
he alone could control the dragons and
the he alone could keep us safe if we
chose to bow down oh I like how he's
narrating and you can still hear the
undertones of Drago's speech you can't
hear him conveying it until he robbed
himself in his cloak and cried now and
see how well you do without me
suddenly burst into flames from it
armored dragons descended holy
I was the only one to escape
you need to toughen up your own dragons
this is what's gonna happen don't worry
bud
I'm not gonna let anything happen to you
I promise I'm a God if anything happens
to toothless I'm gonna be a wreck so we
just don't even don't even what Grace
what is that that looks so spooky oh
thank you
the hell what
are we in a haunted house right now
[Music]
this music sounds heroic though
no get back up fly out fly no no no no
no no no I don't want to see toothless
suffer I can't I can't at all I'm like
don't let this be this kind of movie I
can't handle it my heart cannot handle
this
[Music]
what is that what is that no uh
uh what the hell is going on
what's what is this can are we gonna
reveal that toothless can breathe
underwater it better be that
[Music]
the music's throwing me off
it sounds like positive the music
[Applause]
you're so cool hiccup you're such a
dweeb in the last movie he's a
full-grown teenager now who are you yeah
thank you the dragon Thief Drago blood
fist this person seems so Savage
is that toothless
voice oh thank God save toothless okay
[Music]
oh this person's good
oh this person's real good oh this
person's at the height of their dragon
training
okay
is it a person
the person who's is it just humanoid oh
my God oh my God oh it's a better
trainer than him another trainer is it
his mom
um
that's a great guess oh my God is it
haircut
I think you're right
she know
she just knows his face can I know you
you're only a babe but a mother never
forgets I I knew it what the hell what
she's just like a massive Dragon Tamer
too what are the odds he had it in his
blood he never knew it that's why he
denied his dad's like side of being a
viking so much because he had his mama
side in him
[Music]
all right
these movies are directed so well like
the framing is so good that in his hands
though it looks so tiny in his dad's
hands like like it's rare you watch an
animated movie where you get a sense of
the camera
everyone thinks you were eaten bye
uh does she have a dragon world
she's got oh my God she's been like
breeding amazing dragons and taking care
of them
[Music]
this looks straight up like Avatar
that's so pretty yeah the last one had
an avatar-esque this right here Avatar
exactly
this is where you've been for 20 years
you've been rescuing them
interesting so she's like a little sort
of language barrier or she's like
socially off here I'm not sure maybe it
might very well be the last of his kind
oh look he's your age your age
did Drago or his Choppers do this too
I'm actually the one who
shot him down
maybe that's why she couldn't go back
because his dad is still Viking and
wanted to kill the dragons remember
he changed
they all did they were only it were
possible it is possible I tried as well
but people are not capable of change
hiccup oh that is the theme of this
whole movie
wow that's a hell of a transition into a
flashback yeah Burke was a land of kill
or be killed but I believed peace was
possible oh no no no you'll only make it
worse
[Music]
it was a very unpopular opinion a dragon
broke into our house finding you in the
Cradle oh interesting oh he's always had
a connection
proof of every
firmed her belief oh I got goosebumps
two
um
OED Mark yeah that I always wondered
what that Mark was on his chin an
intelligent gentle creature whose Soul
reflected my own
no did they oh my God yeah no
[Applause]
oh they grabbed her okay you and your
father nearly died that night all
because I couldn't kill a dragon ah it
runs in the family
this is a touching ass movie how did you
survive oh Cloud Jumper never meant to
harm me he must have thought I belonged
here in the home of the great bewilder
beast wowie Kate Blanchette that's her
name is
yes actress in tart that is so her voice
very few that still exist but he's icy
breath this graceful giant built our
Nest
ah cool he's responsible for all that
destruction he protects us we all live
under his care oh and this has come on
yeah wow this feels like truly like a
legendary
oh
wow I feel like I'm watching a video
game holy crap I
lived among
[Music]
them wow the scale
oh
[Laughter]
it doesn't matter what dragon you show
me none are gonna be toothless he's the
cutest one of all
yeah you're gonna show us the way to
dragon and help Dragon ride is sneaking
to Drago's Camp just kill me now that
could be arranged God who is that voice
though
[Music]
Rihanna Stormfly is very good at
fetching
wow this one is so like not just
visually but emotionally it's just like
so sweeping yeah it's very transportive
wow whoa
oh my God oh my goodness oh
he gets a fish and he gives it to him in
the air that's awesome he's like
Jesus
like you said it's a second coming up
Feast toothless
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
yeah like it's communicating so much
without dialogue yeah the first one did
that too like when it was just it showed
us more than it told to us and this is
doing the same but in like
yeah this is like Epic
detail on the physics is so impressive
this is what it is to be a dragon hiccup
but can you fly
laughs
[Laughter]
you gotta start burning into the
situation man yeah you've done that a
few times
took after me yeah
I'm so sorry hiccup
will you give me another chance
one's so moving I can teach you all that
I've learned these past 20 years
oh so he must be 20.
oh
wow
do you know about this
oh my God oh my goodness she bought a
video game upgrade
we will change the world for all dragons
that sounds amazing
but you still got your dad to contend
with and Chief and Burke and also 20
years of like psychological damage yeah
that too you need therapy man there's no
talking to Drago but we have no we must
protect our own
there's still a stubbornness and uh lack
of belief in people that's what makes
hiccup the the linchpin though yeah it
makes him the one that is actually going
to change it because he he starts with
belief system he wants to communicate
down there a bunch of dragon bones
that's for sure
oh no
[Music]
damn how powerful are those darts this
build up to drag go bad for almost an
hour in still haven't seen him
we just saw him
you're welcome hmm he's he's Maui he
does look a lot like Maui as you can see
I am right on time with a new batch of
dragons just like I promised
is that kit Harrington who was just
talking yeah the the doofus one I have
to hear him again I don't think so
what what just happened what oh yeah
dragon scale dragon skin
all right
jeez if you so much just touch us hiccup
is gonna kick he's only the son of stoic
the vast and the greatest Dragon Master
this world has ever seen I know you're
trying to be threatening but you might
be giving too much information also
stand back we must attack the Dragon
Riders less than once take down their
offer then we will take and this guy is
menacing please
oh protected him
I hate these darts it's interesting
seeing Drago and his mom and like two
different versions of tribal kind of
people yeah how did you get in here see
we were getting you out come on wait
okay uh dad that there's something you
need to know yeah tell me all the way
your wife lives here ex-wife
you may want to take this
I know what you're gonna say stoic
stayed away all of these years and why
didn't I come back to you what sign did
I have that you could change wow this is
why I never married I spent one other
reason
I'm better off without me
I was wrong
Shout Scream say something
as a family now newly reunited they will
have to take drug go down
and also save this no name guys this
guy's totally defecting Signs Now our
friend you are a steaming heap of dragon
duck yeah cool
oh he's not a doofus
oh
this help he's capable when the moment
calls for it love it so we're going to
save your dragons and get out of here
okay now I really think it's Kit
Harington yeah I need to listen when he
speaks I haven't been I just hear him
thank you
saving my life
okay I listen then you might be right it
might be yeah I'm a on board kit
Harrington I think I don't know you
wouldn't believe how much Everything's
changed your son's changed built for the
better
I think we did well with this one though
I think he's just like just as
comfortable as always huh he scared her
and she dropped the fish sir once you
move back in with all your dragons oh
Drago won't even stand a chance she's
not gonna move back in this is her home
and she likes it here
might Sail On Savage sea
[Music]
he
he oh he's always had a soft side home
[Music]
and the music in this one is so good
yeah
it really feels like they're building
out a culture yeah like now that they're
back together the family crest would
look different yeah yeah
toothless always pushing his agendas
but she has a home yes
oh wow wait but who's going to stay
there and take care of all the dragon
stuff what's happening
oh my God it's gonna blow up their whole
home we have to save the dragons Come On
Son
I mean they got a big Alice Alpha dragon
on their hand yeah they do that's true
that big ass snow dragon
wow what a tracking shot
oh man keep it hitting the mountain you
need to draw the alpha out
always that's right specifically
haunting the alpha yeah man oh man but
if he gets tame the alpha they'll be
about nulls
[Applause]
haha cool
yes nice
take him down
oh yeah Dad's gonna have to come face
Drago where where have you been catching
up with Mom
that is something special
oh my God it's amazing
I mean I know they haven't been
murdering any of the humans but at least
go for Drago damn all right whoa
attic boy
I don't know I feel like something
terrible is about to happen yeah I
really don't want Mom to die you cannot
take out dragons they aren't controlled
by the ocean
I brought a Challenger
that scream is terrifying oh he's got an
alpha of his own oh great
that's like actually scary the light and
the dark side
how about that texture looks
whoa what is that oh my goodness
oh God no we're not gonna do this are we
haha
is she gonna be able to tame this black
snow dragon I mean I think they just
gotta defeat it yeah
the way they capture the scope of this
is very impressive
[Music]
yeah did they just kill the alpha I
don't like it
[Music]
and now they think he's the alpha
oh God
no
oh my God no no no no no no no no no no
I did not expect that to happen me
neither
all right let's get to these big ass
dragons really feels like a monster
movie
all of this loss
to rule the world
kind amazing creatures that can bring
people together tear them apart
oh
he's like the super dark version of
Hiccup yeah the world wants peace
that scream is just rooted in so much
torment man no dragon can resist the
Alpha's command he who controls
[Music]
no no no hiccup do the juice do
something I hate this
toothless oh my God oh my God
oh [__] snap out of it
oh no
no
ah dad
stoic
[Music]
a haircut doesn't even know what he did
now get away from him no no he didn't
know oh no no he didn't know
it's not his fault you know that
good dragons under the control of bad
people
do bad things that's really that's so
sad
oh my God God I hate it
what the hell man this one's this is
rough like this is like really tough for
me emotional goddamn
like really
putting their audience to test your pen
is you hate this movie right now
if you just keeping like it's gonna end
on such a sad dark note yeah may they
sing your name with love and fury I know
that you've taken your rightful place at
the table of Kings
so he has to be the leader now
foreign
like Blown Away by how mature this one
is yeah it's like so mature now we don't
have to regret my BDSM because there's
nowhere near what just happened
not the Peacekeeper I thought I was
oh what a shot it was such a wee thing a
feared you wouldn't make it but your
father he never doubted
always said you'd become the strongest
of them all
you have the heart of a chief and the
soul of a dragon only you can bring our
worlds together
jeez that
is who you are son
it's like The Lion King I was so afraid
of becoming my dad or a beautiful shot
how do you become someone
that great that Brave that
selfless
I guess you can only try
it's that fight a chief protects his own
we're going back uh he took all the
dragons
not all of them
what well
okay oh like the baby ones
just take control of these guys too
they're babies they don't listen to
anyone
[Music]
goodness is this Drago just destroying
the whole thing
I feel like I haven't seen her the whole
movie
where are you going
horrifying feels like a Kaiju monster
the way they captured it that's true
mythological creature
[Music]
God uh I'm totally blinking the kind of
Norse mythology yeah oh yeah hey look
it's hiccup
[Applause]
still the leader that rises to the
occasion
oh I just realized he's writing hiccup
what a dick move no he's writing he's
writing toothlessly
imagine if he was right a hiccup that
would look really good
[Music]
you certainly are hard to get rid of
Toothless
poor toothless it's me it's me I'm right
here come back to me oh
try to take him he will not miss a
second time it wasn't your fault but
oh
you'd never hurt him
man this movie oh boy
you are my best friend bud
and a boy that's it
oh you jerk
hang on oh he's down for it
[Music]
we need to get those two apart
trust me bud
you and me
oh whoa
that's it oh the mom said this is what
it means to be a dragon yeah
shut it out toothless stop them now
whoa
ah
now or never
come on buddy he could do it yes wow
it's all over now
or is it
uh what
[Music]
check up
oh is it night Fury's like stuff going
yeah yeah
oh my God
[Music]
he's challenging the alpha to protect
you
wow
[Music]
oh my God
oh everyone's everyone's snapping at us
right right you suck man yeah like you
really oh my God
so much
this is what it is to earn a dragon's
loyalty let this end now
never oh
buddy
I know man
should have just said okay but Night
Fury knows who Night Fury is with all
those things on his back now so you
better watch out
right now
oh
man
nice job toothless iron the nature
oh [__] oh scariest
protects them all
right
oh my gosh
no my little guy
yeah he's just right back to being his
little sweet precious thing
[Music]
more Regal
I don't feel like I'm watching an
animated care I feel like I'm really
watching like animals
[Laughter]
[Music]
not you
you'd make a good Chopper
Skull Crushers you need somebody to look
after him now no no way yeah that's what
makes you a leader man your father it'd
be every bit as proud as I am
thank you
I'm really glad you're here Mom wow what
they've done with this hiccup character
is phenomenal yeah
oh yes oh make it official
the chief has come home hmm
wow this is Burger
oh hell yeah awesome we will change this
world
[Applause]
oh sure they have armies and they have
armadas but we we have how he's playing
with them our dragons
our dragons
oh my god wow this movie is perfect
I thought that was so moving
holy junk I've never been so angry and
then also very like five minutes later
burst into tears during a movie I was so
mad like oh my God please don't do this
to us but wow there's so much that
happened it's based on a book series
totally didn't catch that prior I guess
let's get some names really quick you
were damn you nailed that Tara yeah man
you nailed that it's Kate man I did not
catch Kate Blanchett I can hear her from
a mile away I didn't know that ass yeah
I was wrong because I was calling Ingrid
I don't know where I got that from uh I
didn't know it was an is America Ferrara
but I know she was in the first one I
just whatever there was jeremon it was
Kit Harington okay yeah I got them both
right nailed it
oh my God this is a perfect movie I love
it so much the first one is like so
amazing and great yes and never did I
think that I would be like how did they
do better completely surpass what was
already
an incredible film yeah wow they and and
it's not like it's I'm I'm I I I
remember an element one little thing
about the third movie trailer so I
I know one tiny thing just from the
trailer and I think it's on the cover so
that's why I think I remember it oh
um so I'm like okay I know where it can
go but if I didn't have that image in my
head I would go where do you go from
here because this is like so complete
it's such a complete film absolutely
whereas you know
um
it doesn't end in a way where it's like
oh we're setting up a third one or
something like that okay so to me I'm
just so I'm so dazzled by this one I
found it so impressive and it was so
emotional while since I've seen uh an
animated movie that had me that
emotional this might be
this is like this is gonna be like a top
five top three animated movie for me the
specifically this one yeah yeah I mean
the the emotions that they put the
audience through is insane uh I I mean
even in the first one I felt like they
it was wrapped up in a pretty bow
slightly afterwards but we wanted to see
more of the story of you know Hiccup and
Toothless after they both lost their
legs how did their relationship grow and
like boy oh boy did we see it but also I
love that like they gave him the mark in
the beginning I didn't know it was off
obviously they all they read all the
books and made these movies like the
markanish 10 but like learning all of
that the relationship about what
happened and and his mom is like it's
awesome also why does she look so cool
like her costuming which they're still
costuming an animation uh amazing uh and
for us to learn that that's where he got
it from and that's why his relation in
the beginning with his dad was difficult
and we learned that he got a lot of his
heart and his Dragon stuff from his mom
which was nice to see
um but also the struggles that they had
to go through like in being reconnected
as a family and then being ripped apart
like oh it happened so fast
the the first movies yeah it does happen
really quick when you think about the
time frame of that
because at that moment I was like go
either way the mom could die or the dad
or the dad yeah either either or right
now
um
because the first movie ends where we're
like okay Burke is gonna Embrace dragons
and this movie really Embraces the world
that it is now because like the dragons
are such a prevalent part of
experiencing
um the bonding and the kinship of like a
communal experience of of having dragons
right you know as it was in the first
movie it's just Hiccup and Toothless and
then here you're getting this there's a
whole new kind of world expansion on all
kinds where you got the the completely
malevolent side and and then you have
the side with them on the benevolent
side of it you know um where all these
characters have their their trauma and
you're watching how it all sort of plays
out and manifests and I I think the the
parallels they draw this these themes
about you know the willingness to change
and the power that can come from
Humanity of within and like The Power of
Choice so I I I was so dazzled and moved
like there's such a as much as there's
the dragon experience or such a human
experience yeah
um that they that they flesh out so well
like they never lose sight of their
character-driven narrative one bit it is
the the driving force of this movie you
know because like yeah with Hiccup and
his mom when I first came to to be there
was that tiny cynical part of my brain
that was like how's it going to play out
it's gonna be goofy yeah but then the
way she behaves where he does describers
like kind of like a a feral woman which
she said seemed a little socially
awkward because she hasn't been around
he was like man the attention to detail
on this portrayal is so good because she
does seem a little bit off yes she does
seem a little bit odd and that she's
someone who's just been living with
dragons and not interacting with people
you know I I love that
um and the relationship that she forms
where you you see how they get past
um the hardship really quick and it was
so beautiful I was finding myself V
moved to Tears by just how beautiful
things were and then of course when
things got really sad and tragic and
then hopeful like it was kind of that
all-around tears experience yeah and
then even when you know uh stoic
reunites with her how that doesn't go
down this cliche path that was there's
just so much like this pain underneath
the surface yeah that where there where
there's this Conquest for of love that I
think that's the thing that always moves
me is when you fight Against All Odds
but with the power of love as corny as
that [__] sounds I'm like that's the
stuff that really moves me you know I
thought he was gonna say but we have
love at the end like love and Dragons
yeah
um because I felt like that's what is
like the foundation of the story
especially like you said like you do
feel there's still an underneath
Foundation of like pain that was
experienced with the mom and the dad
when they reunite and then it opens up
that really relationship when he starts
whistling and singing the song that they
both remembered and I I like that hiccup
had that experience to see that it
wasn't so tragic after all it was
terrible that Mom could be around but it
was explained sure there was a little
bit that we needed it didn't feel like
Exposition explained as to why she left
um but then shown how she sort of like
fit back into the world to build up his
trust and enough it didn't take all this
stuff for the dad and the son to trust
her and for the dad to be like will you
come back home with us there wasn't like
a didn't need to be a big fight or any
of that he was just like I still love
you great she gave her explanation it
happened pretty quickly but it happened
in a really believable way that I it was
so nice to see that hiccup got to
experience his parents like he never was
able to being like in love and as a
force and then was able to actually go
and fight with them and it didn't work
out but he did still get that experience
for the rest of his life which is it's
great because he he even says like I
don't know if I'll ever know anybody as
like big and brave and like as Fearless
but like now he has you know his mom on
his side and he hasn't had a lot of
experience with her yet but she is the
definition also of that yeah it's
interesting how the movie Drew this kind
of an unexpected visual parallel between
the mom and the villain Drago because oh
yeah you know like they're they're the
two who got the flashbacks yeah where
you I mean one was a flashback of the
perspective that stoic was having about
him and then of course how he tames and
uses dragons like it's very dictatorship
it's Draconian in the way he goes about
it like he's he's evil yeah but but he's
also someone who's who has a lot of hurt
you know he's got a lot of people hurt
people people hurt people and and then
you draw the parallel with the mom who's
also like again kind of like trying
tribal about her her physicality and
mannerisms and you see the way her
relationship is with the dragons and
then it's like these two this is like a
fight for Souls you know like the souls
within people
um the quality of a soul right and and
you see that that's the thing that truly
forms the relationship with the dragons
I it's the last thing I expected them to
do because they're telling these these
multiple stories here and then they
found this narrative where they draw
this parallel that you you just don't
see coming between the mom because it's
not that obvious they're not they're not
hitting you on overnight at all but it's
there it's in the movie it's it's a
visual represent representation of it
it's the that's where the two Alphas
come head to head is is from the mom's
Alpha and and his Alpha yeah uh and it's
something I just did not anticipate that
this film I thought they were just
telling like okay we got the story of
Rodrigo new villain and now we got the
story with the mom okay and I guess
those are gonna fight at some point or
like oh this is so much deeper and more
nuanced than uh I I could have ever
anticipated and even the handling of
like stoic dying I I I I expected them
when he died to okay he's injured
there's probably going to be some speech
here oh there's no speech no he's just
dead like damn this move is going for
like
so Fantastical yeah it's so it's so like
not realistic but it's treating it with
such great gravitas and realism like
yeah oh he just he's just dead yeah he
died right here and he died on the
battlefield and the way you would sort
of expect to go about it and and died
protecting his son you know uh probably
the way he would want if there's a way
to go it would be this way you know yeah
and I feel like any other movie like the
speech would have came then but they
waited until you know they're they're
doing their whatever they're at the
funeral right they're shooting off and
then me uh he finally gives his speech
of saying like he he doesn't know that
he'll know every anyone else that's as
Brave and it's fearless and all of that
yeah
um which is the reason why I said oh
it's like Lion King because the Sun
backdropped that beautiful shot where
he's like you go see his back in the sun
it's like
yeah he looks like Simba uh it just
reminded me of that of here he comes
he's up and he's rising and he
um he did it also his way like he he
never had to
um be like all compromise and I'll help
fight with you Dad and we're gonna start
off we'll do the war thing it was always
that he even with his mom it was still
like this is the way that I I see it
should go down
um and uh I like that I I guess I just
really respect the gut punch of the
realism of the loss of stoic in that
moment because yeah rather than giving
stoic some like dying speech yeah
that is how lost can go down in the
situation like that like it's so
unexpected so sudden you know yeah
that's Rose really that that like broke
me well that is extra broke me when he
was like get away I was like I started
crying I was already crying I'm about to
scream stop because he didn't mean it he
didn't mean it and that hurt my heart
more than you know uh also because like
he had no idea he did it he didn't no he
just was like oh God it makes my stomach
hurt even talking about like that was
what that movie did to me like it makes
me like uh physically hurt when I think
about it because they put me in a
situation where everything was so
beautiful and sharp and believable yeah
uh just like in the first one we made a
lot of comments about the voiceovers in
this seems so real and I kept saying I
think they put them in a room and make
them move around like I I'm like I
wouldn't be surprised if they're like
here's a kind of a set move around as
you as you feel or it's all miked up in
here because this one made me feel the
exact same way like I'm just taken into
this world and there's nothing that
brings me out of it not even the comedic
characters and in a lot of live action
they try to do the same thing as this
where then they're still like the nerdy
character who makes some jokes brings
some levity to a situation like right
after the I think the dad died it was
like his friend made like oh all right
we're we're going down here now I don't
remember and it was like it's a little
light-hearted thing I didn't mind it it
didn't throw me off too much it was one
little piece of levity that fit in and
they didn't try too hard to like hit us
over the head with that to make it like
oh this is still a fun movie because
they were scared we would all be like
well what we were I was like I was mad I
was angry and then I was very sad but um
those moments that brought levity the
situation
um they were they were great and
everything was done in a real graceful
manner with like little
tidbits that we needed without drawing
it out so much yeah they just were like
this is
this is enough I think for the movie
we're gonna move on now and trust us
when it all comes together you will have
ridden through a roller coaster and been
taken through a journey of not feeling
just for one or two characters of really
feeling for a lot and each one of them I
really thought it was going to end
shortly after stoic died me too and I
was like we're gonna end on like a
Darkness I was like yeah right and then
you're like now I have to watch three
right away otherwise I really thought
that's where we were going yeah me too
um uh it's so impressive what they've
done with Hiccup
like when you think about his character
in the first one like you're really
watching this guy grow up not just
physically yeah like he's he's so
maturing that if you were to look at who
he was in the first like
even at the end of the first movie he
would become the leader of the Vikings
of the people of Burke yeah I wouldn't
be like I really I don't know about that
I'd be like he's a little too scared he
doesn't know he's a little too like uh
dorky yeah and they don't like they
don't like character assassinate they
don't rewrite him no they just let him
grow let him grow up that by the time he
becomes the leader and he's like not at
all emulating the mannerisms of his dad
he's not trying to turn him into his dad
he's they're just letting him be his own
identity and you really believe him as
yes you are the leader yeah you are the
right person for this
um they're letting him go from being a
boy really evolving into a man yeah in a
way that is insanely believable for
something that I again did not
anticipate that this movie would go down
the route over attempt to pull and then
the evolution of Hiccup
um I mean God damn it um
um the evolution of two plus two is like
he's coming just like power set yeah uh
they they still keep that as the core of
the even though it's like it gets bigger
and more Grand it's not just about
Toothless and Hiccup they still keep it
at the center yeah I agree like like in
what I said and kind of what you were
saying of like he did it on he did it
still being fully hiccup the entire time
yeah and even at the end he's still the
hiccup we knew before he's just now the
leader that they all needed but it's
funny they both did need Mom and even uh
you know toothless obviously needed mom
to like bring out the scales on his back
that's the only reason he was able to do
that final move yeah with Hiccup at the
very end where you're like
oh man that's awesome and I also feel
like a little bit of that it's like
toothless now became fully who he is he
was so excited when his mom found like
that and he was like oh they're here
like as though he forgot kind of and
then that that made him more powerful in
that moment but I also think maybe in
that moment of like he was now fully
formed toothless right with his you know
owner being able to fight back and
through that ice that he right at the
very end where it's like oh man he he
it's like uh hiccup could only do so
much and did like almost like a hundred
percent but I kind of think like oh man
like they both kind of really needed mom
to come through because if mom hadn't
known that like spot I don't know if
hiccup would have ever found it sure and
it really did bring toothless to life I
think in a lot of ways and it's really
is so exciting to see that Mom is there
she's now in the home and she's getting
to finally have that time with her son
that she lost for the 20 years in a
world that now brought the combination
of her world where she was living for 20
years along with her son's world
together because I thought when I saw
the sadness in her eyes when Dad was
like do you want to come back and live
with us I thought she was going to be
like
but my home is here now and I take care
of these dragons this is the world I've
lived here for 20 years I really thought
she might say that and then she said yes
she would come home so I'm sure they
would have figured it out but now in
seeing it I was like oh but she did get
what she wanted the dragons from her
home came to uh hiccup's home to Burke
and now she she gets that life which is
really
I mean I'll love to see what three is
it's such a good story we got we gotta
wrap it up we gotta wrap it up listen
the last thing I give it nine out of ten
ten out of ten I mean I don't know 11
out of ten like out of everything like
it was all we talked about was the story
of characters yes the animation is
[__] Flawless
oh yeah the animation yeah
um the animation is Flawless yeah I love
the the attention to detail and the
physicality and of course like there was
I noticed there's a lot more like motion
happening in the background like the
environments that were lived in uh music
once again sweeping like all the
technical scale stuff is like it didn't
feel like an animated movie that's why I
was like I don't even need to comment on
it this is such a real movie I don't
even see it as like truly cinematic yeah
like no one here I've seen a good amount
of animated [__] here and this is like
this is Top This is top this is like the
this is probably the best the best the
best one I've seen like personally like
reacted to it this might be the the best
one I've personally like watched I had a
camera pointed at me and watched it like
no one's saying you should watch How to
Train Your Dragon is ever gonna go it's
an animated movie and you do that with
animated movies sometimes I'm like this
these movies you don't even have to it
doesn't even matter it's just saying
like this is a beautiful film and I the
animation doesn't even it's so good it
doesn't even it just clocks in my brain
is a beautiful movie yeah it's great 10
uh 11 stars out of 10. we love it tell
us what you guys think comment like you
know do the deal we love you so much and
uh I'm tired from crying being mad and
crying but uh that's all that's all we
got we'll see you on the on the next one
we love you so much bye
foreign